situations like this where you sit
together with your team in your team
room working late facing these tough
challenges at work these were the
situations that at least for me often
led to building the deepest bonds with
your colleagues the people I've worked
with on these projects often tended to
be the people that then I like to hang
out with most also after the project
this is the material out of which these
War Stories are Bid then you can talk
about and think about back even years
after you left the job so again while I
know that in the very moment this
doesn't help also look at it from this
perspective that you probably in a
couple of years will look back and also
see some positive thoughts that you took
out of this experience